let's talk about Kung Fu Panda 3 you
work with Jackie Chan on all three
movies but what's fascinating about
animation you didn't meet Jackie Chan
until just recently made you've made
three full movies with him never met him
and then how did you come to meet him
this time yet we work together literally
10 years yeah side-by-side on one of the
most successful franchises of all time
never met the man never so much as a
high five not even like a glance from
across the room we've never been within
a hundred yards of each other yeah and
it's because they record you guys in
separate areas exactly that's how the
process is anyone who's familiar with
the animated process but so recently
like a couple weeks ago as in in China
in Shanghai mm-hmm and I'm doing a
junket doing some interviews talking
about the movie and then a dude comes up
and says mr. Chen would like to speak
with you that's like what would Jackie
Chan yes follow me sir
I was like yeah I'm following and I got
up and I left the middle of the
interview and we went to the special
elevator oh my god this is happening
because I've been dying to meet him and
we get to a special hotel suite
penthouse doors open in Shanghai Jackie
Chan's famous everywhere but in Shanghai
he is like a god he's like yeah yeah
he's got there's a certain power he has
to stay hidden away because he's like a
beetle literally people screaming
freaked out right so I go in and I have
I passed by like 50 his crew runs deep
like 15 deep and I get and then I see
the man and his auras just glowing his
eye hello mr. black and we had like this
powerful shake and we had this amazing
eye contact transferal of energies and
he said um think of a movie we'd do it
how they all right and then he said I
have to prepare so I said don't take up
your time but I know that he was serious
that all I have to do is like think of a
good movie he wasn't talking about
another Kong coupe and he was talking
like a new project yeah well suddenly
new yeah it should be great people would
love to see you dude what's the idea
what do you think you gonna do I don't
really I'm still it's kind of I only
have crappy ideas so far but I think
right now what I'm working on is a show
it may be like because I love cuisine I
love to eat and I was think maybe a
movie called
cheeseburger where I'm like a chef and
he's like a chef and we're competing
hamburger chef's I don't know what it is
but I know that there's like on the
poster there'll be like a bun and a bun
and me laying here going and then ham
laying on top of me like another piece
of meat and then please don't ever pick
to be good so you're just gonna you're
right he's in on whatever you come up
with and sequel is so obvious
double cheeseburger picture this is the
picture of your famous meeting yeah
Jackie Chan thanks thanks team 30s
gangster he was hiding his hair because
he's got a special top-secret dude
that's gonna be in his next movie he
couldn't let me see it oh really yeah no
one can see the do No that's great
that's a great exclusive that you have
yeah any ideas for cheeseburger cuz I
know you're a tremendous writer you like
one of my favorite writers
thank you probably didn't know he's like
the most kick-ass writer in Hollywood no
please funniest thing ever
please I do have a lot of ideas you have
to make it there has to be kung-fu
incorporated into hamburger right you
have to have fighting no because that's
what people want to see so how you'll do
that people will be pissed off if
there's no kung-fu in cheeseburger so
yeah there's probably gonna be like an
evil hamburger chef that wants to steal
our recipe for nefarious reasons I don't
know know what Iraq eat was a reformed
assassin yeah who went into the burger
business to get out of that life yeah
interesting
yeah and that I did he ask - because
you're threatened he has to go back to
his fighting skills even though he's
sworn never to kung fu again
would you think when you consider riding
it on spec I'll write it on a napkin and
tell you what you write it alright and
it's happening it's all right done
I think Andy cracked it oh no no not
hold it what you can do that this
weekend I'll do it leave I'll do
whatever